i gotta ask you because problems like
what was like a moment a big moment for
for the city man like that was like um
that was [ __ ] crazy i just remember
that record and like how it
cut through just i was living in
no i was living in phoenix at the time
but that song was such a
that song changed a lot of people's
lives yeah yes um how did it like like
tell me about that song it just that
you know i love that that run problem
was on the the mollywood runs like i
mean you know
i feel like
he had it for like you know cool three
years i feel like like when i thought of
la i thought a problem you know what i'm
saying like and he's still doing his
thing obviously but that specific record
changed a lot
yeah so with that record like
um that was the last record that we did
on you know that that uh project and
problem produces himself
um and you know he he had the ideal for
it and everything and
you know he just brought it to me
um and i just kind of put my my mix on
it um and you know my drums and and just
turned it around like you know changed
the main lead and
you know it just went crazy
yeah that [ __ ]
yes for a while you guys have you guys
had the same manager so he just kind of
had the pick of the litter of this
league of stars beats for a while there
yeah but that was like at that that was
early right yeah at that point so we was
coming out of the jerk era
and you know like i had a bunch of
records in the jerk area i was like
popping you know and then it died out
which which records did you have so like
from the jerk area of course tie me down
um i did shia model for yg um and just a
bunch of like just random stuff like
taft like everybody that was pretty much
popping and um
like it started to die out my name
started to you know kind of fizzle out
with it as well and i started seeing
like the pre-denies which who are my
homies you know from
way back uh they were starting to come
up so you know like i joined league of
stars and like
that was like really my turn around
record because i was just trying to
put something out you know i didn't have
no records out there who didn't function
that was training
yeah so at that time that just that just
kind of turned everything around for me
and you know like just re you know
introducing myself back into
the scene